hello everybody my name is Marc Lauren
welcome back to what may be the last
episode of draw 'fl I'm here with Wade
Jesse and Matt hey Matt hey guys yeah if
you didn't know Matt is actually helping
me out and he's my new editor and
finally in the first time in three years
I haven't had an editor this entire time
and he's helping me out a ton so if you
see any screw-ups in any videos in the
recent years or days tell his fault
don't blame him and blame him for any
screw-ups in the future okay cool all
right cool
ready to play I'm ready to play this is
actually the first let's play you've
ever been in ever it is I'm excited yeah
actually the other so the other cynical
guys are right over there but you guys
did lets plays as like challenges one
time yeah yeah I should really like say
that play they were really fun there are
a lot fun cuz they always involve dares
and challenges which I kind of want to
do more of after we did the baby food
one so if you haven't seen the other two
episodes to draw fell'd they're down in
the description if you haven't seen the
baby food challenge that's probably out
and you should see that and if you
haven't seen the whisper challenge with
Jesse and Mathias and Wade there's that
and then the next week there will be
another challenge the seven second
challenge which was made up by Dan and
Phil or maybe not made up by damn Paul I
have no idea yeah either way let's go oh
I'm testicle lips if that wasn't clear I
would never
I'm Daniel Daniel I rule Oh Bobby I'm up
Bobby you shouldn't be smoking that dang
cream Bobby Bobby that's some damn dank
Kush damn dank cookie okay
I wonder
and hit the wrong one
yes you did you really winner comes up
whoa yeah that's you kidding given me
more points man I wanted such an idiot
I was trying okay all right good nation
I'm off to a good start the test Agathe
lips the test doc testicle oops
we got ass to copy cannot where there's
no back you need to win this one for me
I've been a convincing time I can read
the words nothing
whose is this
it's mine okay no words words are
cheating oh my god you're such an idiot
you were just like your channel Ryan
okay okay
spice it up with some like splash
graphics show off your editing skills in
this one cuz like the first time people
know it's higher of age good swear you
go it's Russian polish it would be
amazing if it was what you do the users
I do this Wow
as I like up did a music stand of course
it was gonna be a monitor but I didn't
monitor it yeah that's not anything what
is that's a card you know that's it's
projected freaking idiot more airhorns
get some anime in what whoa whoa oh God
is the heaviness oh you can't even
really isn't really if my god how do you
do it there's a nice big guitar yeah
this is chicken this tribute chicken I'm
definitely a night I oh you suck oh you
suck
on the bull you suck so hard
I hate you oh holy bagga-t oh don't walk
okay here are your choices
oh holy buckets watch it's [ __ ] even a
thing which white wine is a work no I
mean in French is it still I don't know
free and high school people call meat
Watson's my name was Matt Watson my
parents naturally put [ __ ] in money are
you sure that's why there's another
reason
well them exactly no oh man no one
picked a home let bad guys don't watch
no no oh look at thank you I god damn it
Bobby
oh god damn it we can't let bank
what is Wow balls yeah that looks out of
a microwave under yeah a testicle under
a microwave cooking together indeed
thank you oh my god yes how is how is
that warm buns Wow Google a sponge brush
all explain your actions you guys all
knew what it was explain yourself
well yeah bonds like but Harry but and
then
yeah the line with sketchy though and I
love me points you little [ __ ]
god dammit I hate you so much
thanks for the point I'm real like one
for someone give me enough to win if you
had just given me points in the last one
you piece of crap
oh yeah blast what wins it all first two
games don't count
Matt's away they got the most likes
humid well there we go then
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching this has been draw 'fl I
had a lot of fun hope you did too
go check out Wade's channel dezzy's
Twitter's nothing it's a wasteland if
it's just a pity but Matt here has his
own channel it's called the kids with
problems go check it out he has some
music videos up there and a few other
cool things that you can check out and
wish him luck on editing the rest of my
stuff from now on he's gonna be helping
me out a great deal to get you even more
cool stuff in the future if I mess up
please don't tattle on me I am going to
be looking very closely so please don't
get in trouble
seriously guys please alright cool
thanks again everybody if you want to
see more of this let us know we we they
are actually flying out so thank you
guys so much for being here like in all
honesty really happy that you guys came
along I do love hanging out with them
being serious you look at me like oh
this [ __ ] deals like
I believe nothing thanks so much for
coming by they're flying out tomorrow
yeah but if you guys want more from
anyone else let us know if you want more
challenges let us know thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always we will see you in the next video
bye bye you know what you are absolutely
right you ready be on an even playing
field here
I bet you